Joe rogan experience Joe Rogan podcast.
My name's
Jane Goodall.
At least 100%
I found that fascinating.
And um,
the,
the reason being is that there's an actual animal represents called gigantic and
it would say that's more than eight feet tall that lived in the most recently we
know of a hundred thousand years ago.
So that's not outside the realm of possibility.
If you look at what we've learned today about things that we thought were
extinct,
whether it's,
you know,
the Goblin shark or whatever it's been looking at,
or maybe four point there because it's still within the realm of an ape like
thing.
Yeah.
Which is different from the other cryptos all logical folks who say they were
dragging.
You get life forms that have no counterpart.
Yes.
Anywhere else.
It's a real animal.
I mean,
they have home stay out of the fossils.
They know that it's real animal.
They actually found their teeth in the apothecary shop and like a public area in
like the 1920s gigantic quite make to that,
that they couldn't understand.
They were like,
what the fuck is this?
They knew it was probably,
we knew it was enormous.
So it eventually led to a digs in China where they found these gigantic pivots
buried their dead.
Really fascinating stuff.
So that that's a high level of intelligence and respect for their dead.
You know,
it's really interesting stuff.
And the um,
the Pacific northwest is a crazy spot and it's exactly where they would come if
it came down the Bering strait with humans.
It's really interesting stuff because we know they existed with humans.
We know it was a real animal coexistence.
Yeah.
Would they unquestionably side by side in Asia a hundred thousand years ago,
at least.
That's,
that's solid.
So it's,
that's a blip a hundred thousand years.
Especially when you look at like the Pacific northwest and how dense it is.
Well,
she's saying,
she's saying that it existed at some point,
but she's not agreeing.
You're still,
but randomly,
actually this is still there.
She thinks enough people have seen the same thing when they brought
there.
First of all,
they have gray hair like silver,
the big old
six foot tall
gray hair.
They have photos of dead ones,
couple hundred shot,
no question.
It's a totally,
believe it or not,
this is more people go through
at least this particular where they found these gems,
they have a video of one.
So there's an interesting
fundamental fact.
Okay,
I'm gonna make up a story.
There exist a creature that is large and each every human who has come up too,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
how do you
know what I said about big foot is that a big foot is due right next to the
grill is no one gives a shit.
And if,
uh,
if God didn't exist,
it would be mythological and animal that is smart as a human,
maybe without three before cortex 40% larger than a person sees people to fall
in the ocean and kill sharks.
Kills sharps.
Big Four.
Can't kill a fucking sharp know.
Think about the shit that killer whales.
Nothing pops of the killer whale except for people because that sentence,
big can't kill.
I like these assertions,
knows the shots from the jacket.
It's not going to be split tasks.
Your arguments they have in comic con,
you know,
or Kevin Smith through.
They have a whole four hour podcasts.
Look when big word,
a Sasquatch or big foot or a sharp,
yeah,
it's the idea of the animals.
It's just like we were talking about earlier,
the idea that we're,
that we're actually picking shit.
Brilliant
things that nobody else does.
Scotland.
Let's say I called it,
I told Ya
who was doing all your own stuff
or no,
this one is like seven years old and this one is like that one.
That's cool.
Graphics that I drew that
do draw
the guy named Danny Williams Tattoo that he's dead now.
Got Cancer.
The Dixon cause I want to go.
Not Good.
Wow.
That's very Japanese style off us.
This is not what I drew.
I drew this.
This is load up to massage.
This is Musashi versus Aaron.
Tell the dog what does all this kind of Japanese like no tattoos.
You,
you should go full.
Yakuza bar
in [inaudible] will be here.
I have to call Rick.
Rick Ross.
Okay.
You're going to have her draws on it.
I've had no,
the not the wrapper.
Rick Ross Criminal Syndicate boss who I went to,
Jim [inaudible] who was a big waste.
Oh.
Can we do it together?
What?
Three free smoke to off on the down on the points.
Three like this.
There'll be a couple posts,
a message.
I'll get presents.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Ready.
Go.
Oh,
you broke it.
Panics.
I can't tell you that.
A big deal.
That was fine.
Oh,
that's awesome man.
I smoke like you live with us.
Constant.
Okay.
Pop the pop.
Enjoyed it.
I'm glad I did.
It was a lot of fun.
Next word.
Match skin.
What is it?
It's dude's would the hard Dick's in their pants.
Funding their boners thinking third,
their underwear.
Why you paid money for this?
You really want that.
This is one of those things.
Oh,
well if you don't water,
I'll say I bought it for you really drunk the next day.
I was like,
why did I,
okay.